ton municipal on a essayé de parler de
la vie on a tenté de parler de la
fiscalité de la sécurité il faut qu'on
parle un petit peu l'élection qui va
venir et et francine weecksteen moi
j'avais envie de vous demander comment
vous positionner dans cette élection on
sait que c'est une liste sans étiquette
vous avez défendu le bilan de daniel
paris cependant cette émission est ce
que vous vous situez dans cette droite
ligne
je me situe déjà dans une perspective de
2014 2020 et je ne regarde pas dans le
rétroviseur et je veux aller de l'avant
et effectivement pour moi l'important
c'était c'était de réunir les forces
vives de la ville autour d'un projet
autour d'un projet que nous avons
construit avec avec cette équipe qui
m'entoure depuis de longs mois et qui
enfin depuis septembre et qui a voulu
effectivement construire sur les bases
d'une union large au niveau du
territoire à la fois des personnes de
droite des personnes de gauche et
surtout des personnes qui sont motivés à
construire ce projet pour la ville de
sens
voilà c'est c'est socialement sans
étiquette effectivement mais je ne je
sens en réponse à ma question sur
poursuite poursuite de l'équipe
précédente ou pas non c'est je m'inscris
dans un nouveau projet dans un nouveau
projet pour la ville avec des personnes
qui viennent à la fois de droite et de
gauche merci monsieur moreau vous
faisiez partie de la municipalité
défaite en 2008 madame fort et vous
revenez au combat aujourd'hui avez-vous
retenu les leçons de votre échec
en rajoutant chaleur et moraux que quand
on est battus parfois c'est que les
électeurs veulent envoyer un message
donc quand on veut revenir est ce que
votre équipe a tenu compte du message
qu'ils avaient peut-être été envoyé à
l'époque à partir du moment où on perd
c'est sûr que l'on que l'on réfléchit
toujours ce qu'il faut
ce qui est déplorable hausse et c'est
effectivement et je pense pour le pour
le bien de la ville de sens c'est que on
assiste quand même à zapping politique
depuis de nombreuses années
alors c'est vrai que quand quand
j'entends madame d'aquitaine parler de
bon sens j'aurais envie de dire enfin
parce que
pourquoi même osé dire le bon sens après
avoir avoir tenu tenu les affaires non
il n'était pas content
effectivement
c'est pour ça que nous avons nous avons
construit une liste qui est qui est
compétente qui est expérimenté avec des
personnes compétentes et expérimentées
qui qui a un certain nombre de perse de
personnes qui étaient investis dans
l'opposition municipale ces dernières
années qui ont pu malheureusement
constater ce qui ce qui s'était passé et
on a aussi avec nous un certain nombre
de jeunes un certain nombre de jeux
d'hier de personnes issues des milieux
associatifs
issus de la société civile de façon
vraiment redonné une nouvelle
gouvernance à 7 à cette ville je pense
que les sénonais s'attendent à ce que
alors c'est dommage de parfois parce que
ce se débat aujourd'hui étaient un peu
désorientés par des interventions jédir
à l'extérieur mais je pense qu'il faut
aussi envoyer un message au niveau des
niveaux de sénèque est un message
d'abord positif et puis ensuite un
message de compétences et sérieux de
façon à ce qu'on remette une véritable
gouvernance dans cette ville alors je
rebondis sur ce que vous avez dit sur
internet nous a été posée nous on était
posé plusieurs questions qui la question
poser c'est est-ce que
peut-il y avoir des arrangements entre
l'ump et le front national et les
discussions sur sens quelqu'un nous
rajoute puisque edouard ferrand a été
récemment invités par madame morano un
repas en saône et loire alors d'abord
monsieur moreau est ce que vous pourriez
être amené à discuter et puis ensuite
edouard ferrand alors j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on a discuté depuis tout
à l'heure avec monsieur ferrand donc si
je réponds rien que parent je dirais la
situation représente non je pense qu'il
ya la première des choses qu'il faut
dire c'est qu'on respecte les électeurs
les acteurs font des choix mais c'est
aussi à nous de les convaincre que
parfois leur choix moi je trouve
aujourd'hui voter voter pour le front
national c'est favoriser la gauche donc
je pense qu'il faut le dire absolument
clairement sur ce sur ce plan là donc un
respect d'abord des électeurs et puis
ensuite une réponse nette et claire
n'ont aucune alliance au deuxième tour
edouard ferrand ça s'appelle une réponse
de l'onba vous êtes allés déjeuner avec
nadine morano exactement cette semaine
il y avait l'inauguration du stand
bourgogne au salon de l'agriculture et
il y avait une table avec tous les élus
donc il y avait des élus du front
national de gauche de droite donc voilà
tout le monde était présent et je pense
que la bourgogne sait se rassembler
aussi sur ses côté festif et donc voilà
on peut parler aussi d'autre chose que
de la politique voilà simplement donc la
réponse à la crise
moi ce que je voudrais simplement dire
c'est que cette semaine l'express a
classé le département de l'yonne au 86e
rang sur 4 95 départements où il fait
bon vivre sens attendu au moins deux
mille habitants depuis dix ans je crois
qu'il ya un d'éclat et il faut pas être
fataliste il y avait une réponse à ma
question s'adorent ferrand ma question
c'était si vous vous retrouviez qualifié
pour le deuxième tour l'ump aussi ou
dans d'autres scénarios est ce que vous
envisageriez vous souhaiteriez parler
avec moi je ne suis ni de gauche ni de
droite je rassemble les patriotes qui
n'en peuvent plus justement de l'ump s
je crois qu'au contraire ce que veulent
les sénonais c'est un grand coup de
balai moi je rassemble les patriotes
tous les déçus de la gauche tous les
petits français qui aujourd'hui on en
marre de cette situation politique à
sens magouilles et bien moi je crois que
il ya un nouveau message c'est le
message de malice qui s'appelle osons le
bon sens il y aura des gens qui vont
pouvoir justement se retrouver avec des
gens compétents récemment vous aviez
pourtant dit dans lors d'une conférence
de presse que vous étiez prête à une
alliance moi je suis prêt à une alliance
avec des gens avec qui ils ont un projet
cohérent parce que si on veut changer
nationale il faut commencer par le local
est aujourd'hui il peut y avoir des
listes sans étiquette qui sont prêts à
sens comme ailleurs à vouloir partager
un bout de chemin avec nous on est prêt
à les regarder et les écouter michel
fourré
comment vous vous positionnez dans cette
élection et est ce que le grand nombre
de listes y en a sept as ans
compliquer ou rend la situation plus
incertaine
évidemment la situation est incertaine
c'est évident d'autant plus que quand on
regarde les programmes de tous les
candidats à part monsieur edouard
ferrand nous avons à peu près tous plus
ou moins les mêmes idées sur l'avenir de
la ville mais pour moi je suis plutôt
classés dans les divers gauche c'est
comme ça que vous êtes
donc vous n'oublierez pas quand même que
lors de la législative dernière nous
avons mois et un certain nombre de mes
colistiers soutenu nicolas soret du
parti socialiste et que donc nous
montrons bien notre orientation
mais moi ça me démange elle annonce ça
peut annoncer des discussions ce que
vous venez de donner à nous ne voyons
aucune discussion avec mon voisin pour
l'instant non il ya eu aucune discussion
possible d'ailleurs
c'est possible on verra après il pourra
répondre
il nous reste une minute trente avant
les conclusions il va nous répondre donc
moi l'intérêt de la chose c'est que nous
sommes une liste apolitique et nous
n'avons aucune directive de toutes les
pages de tous les partis ce qui nous
permet d'avoir quand même facilement
notre idée propre sur la question est de
travailler entre nous pour diriger cette
ville mais moi je veux dire franchement
depuis que je suis maire j'ai essayé par
tous les moyens d'améliorer nos
relations entre l'opposition et la
majorité
même la majorité plus ou moins éclatée
et que je pense que nous avons travaillé
dans de bonnes conditions et sérénité je
vais donner la parole à pascal simon
avant les conclusions quand même
remettre les choses au clair
auch à michel s'est il ya quand même eu
des déclarations qui étaient très très
net est écrite en disant que votre
groupe n'était pas compatible avec la
gauche rassemblée tels que nous
l'incarnons qui passe sans cesse se
donner demain donc je trouve ça quand
même un petit peu juste de jouer sur le
de jouer sur l'ambiguïté et de se
positionner comme ça un peu au centre
gauche alors que quand on était en
position de faire des alliances
personnes a répondu à nos appels ceci
étant dit ceci étant dit nous sommes le
parti socialiste et j'en ai absolument
aucune honte on a toutes les composantes
au ps nous sommes le parti communiste on
est là depuis 6 ans et pas marqué sur
vos documents c'est marqué sur nos
documents on vient d'avoir géré marché
on n'a pas honte je vais être obligé de
d'interrompre cette discussion puisque
on en arrive à l'heure des conclusions 1
c'est ce qu'on vous avait proposé une
conclusion pour chacun dans un ordre qui
a été tiré au sort préalablement et le
tirage au sort nous a donné pour
commencer honneur aux dames francine
weecksteen pour votre conclusion
que dire pour conclure le pour nous le
bon sens nous dit que c'est la réunion
de toutes les énergies qui nous
permettra de permettre l'épanouissement
de la ville le bon sens nous invite à ne
pas réitérer les erreurs du passé et à
ne pas mettre à la tête de la ville des
personnes qui ne représentent qu'une
faible partie de la population
le bon sens comme je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure n'est ni de droite ni de gauche
il est d'abord devant et c'est devant
que nous allons à la rencontre des
habitants en faisant et du porte à porte
en les écoutant et en les connaissant de
mieux en mieux et en en sachant quelles
sont leurs étals aux attentes le plus
important pour nous pour notre liste
s'est laissé nos nez et les cenonnaise
le projet que nous portons est le vôtre
ce que je veux faire pour ma ville je le
fais pour les pour vous ces monnaies et
cenonnaise ma détermination sera
identique à celle qui m'a animé lors de
ces 25 dernières années et lors de mes
différents engagements c'est ensemble
que nous allons parcourir ce nouveau
chemin sur lequel chacun à sa place
merci francine weecksteen
deuxième à conclure charles hervé moreau
oui le 23 et le 30 mars prochain chaque
sénonais va faire un choix importants
pour l'avenir de notre ville
il devra garder en mémoire c'est six
années d'errements qui ont conduit la
ville dans une impasse
et ne pas oublier que dans beaucoup de
listes ce sont les mêmes qui se
représentent et qui promettent ce qu'ils
n'ont pas pu réaliser ces six dernières
années
l'équipe autour de marie louise fort à
la volonté de redonner à sens de la
gouvernance de la confiance et du
dynamisme c'est une équipe compétente
expérimentée
disponibles issues de la société civile
des milieux associatifs
et des différents quartiers de la ville
on sait nous nous sommes engagés sur
quatre points le pourcentage de la
population qui vous est donné
à 0 % de hausse des taux communaux la
lutte contre la sécurité le renforcement
de l'attractivité de sens pour
développer l'emploi et le développement
de la qualité de vie à sens de l'enfance
à la dépendance merci charles hervé
moreau troisième à conclure michel
fourré
moi j'ai pas de papiers bon eh bien
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est surtout de
redonner des droits aux sénonais
dans le domaine du social c'est à dire
que tout le monde puisse avoir au moins
un minimum comme le rsa
dans le dans le domaine des personnes
âgées souvent isolées
et qui ont des droits mais qu'ils ne
savent pas il faut absolument que nous
puissions travailler et récupérer toutes
ces personnes âgées seules dans leur
logement et de pouvoir les accueillir
d'une façon correcte
il ya du travail évidemment on fait faut
qu'on fasse venir des entreprises c'est
tout à fait fondamental sans ça ce n'est
pas possible mais la santé évidemment
il ya beaucoup de gens qui n'ont qui
n'ont qu'en pas de prod compagne
mutuelle et qui vraiment ne vont plus
dans les services de santé vous ouvriez
il faut pas oublier que j'ai été pendant
quinze ans aux urgences et que j'ai vu
la misère humaine
dans ce sens merci michel fourré pascal
simon ici le respecte il tend un don
quercy avec avec sens demain ce que je
propose c'est une vraie rupture avec les
lettristes année fort et parisse est un
réel renouvellement du port celle du
personnel politique je veux rassembler
sur les valeurs de la gauche et montrer
qu une politique de progrès est possible
pour notre ville vous mobiliser en ma
faveur dès le premier tour est la seule
chance la seule chance de battre la
droite et d'éloigner l'extrême droite
d'un score qui serait preuve en est
encore aujourd'hui avec monsieur ferrand
qui serait une honte pour notre ville
l'abstention c'est clairement une prime
qui est donnée au front national alors
je serai dès demain sur les marchés dans
les rues dans les cages d'escalier pour
expliquer notre programme voilà merci
edouard ferrand à vous de conclure
notre micro prenez votre micro oui
pardon
pour en finir avec le communautarisme
pour une ville qui défend son identité
son identité cenonnaise son identité
française depuis 15 ans je siège au
conseil régional j'ai été c'est en
conseil municipal de sao suzanne homme
d'expérience j'ai avec moi un futur
premier adjoint raphaël pour roy qui est
ingénieur dans une très grande
entreprise cenonnaise j'ai avec moi pour
les affaires financières le directeur
d'une maison de retraite à côté de sens
un professeur des écoles chaque
feliciano pour ce qui concerne
l'enseignement aujourd'hui à une équipe
de gens compétents une équipe prête pour
demain une équipe qui a du talent une
équipe qui va oser le bon sens voter
pour la liste rassemblement bleu marine
pour sens merci nous voilà au bout de
cet exercice imposé merci à tous les
cinq d'être venus débattre merci pascal
d'avoir participé à ce débat la semaine
prochaine rendez-vous à chalon sur saône
en saône et loire pour un autre débat au
revoir